sur europe bonjour et bienvenue dans un
europe / sensation une émission
enregistrée au parlement européen est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
dans quelques instants l'eurodéputé
nicolas bay sera mon invité l'occasion
d'évoquer le bras de fer entre l'union
européenne et la turquie et la crise
migratoire en europe
les pères fondateurs de l'europe nous
vous parlerons de paul henri spaak l'un
des premiers hommes politiques à avoir
une vision de coopération européenne
voyager dans l'assiette vous découvrirez
un plat typiquement britannique
le fish and chips les expressions
populaires pleuvoir en abondance les
français disent pleuvoir comme vache qui
pisse pour les grecs
il pleut des pieds de chaise que dit-on
ailleurs c'est ce que vous verrez à la
fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite saône
robe l'europe dans ma région
comment intéresser les jeunes et les
personnes isolées aux questions de
l'europe et pourquoi faut-il
s'intéresser à l'europe bonjour à tous
je reçois aujourd'hui olivier jeanne ou
ex chargé de mission à la maison de
l'europe des yvelines bonjour alors tout
au long de l'année la maison de l'europe
des yvelines organise plusieurs
événements et actions autour de l'europe
quels sont les objectifs de la maison de
l'europe des yvelines la maison de
l'europe des yvelines a pour objectif en
fait d'informer et de renseigner et
surtout de sensibiliser les gens à
l'europe et donc pour cela en fait on ne
remplace différentes actions on a des
actions d'information donc par exemple
on fait d organiser des animations dans
les établissements ont fait des
événements grand public
on organise aussi des projets ou en fait
on va envoyer des personnes par exemple
en stage professionnel ou en mission de
volontariat
grâce au programme européen et que vous
avez mis en place un nouveau projet
l'europe en live elle y avait eu
quelques besoins répond ce projet et
comment at il pu être mis en place
en fait ce projet s'inscrit dans une
réflexion plus globale qui a lieu au
sein de l'union européenne qui s'appelle
la conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
qui est un grand exercice démocratique
qui est impulsée par les institutions
européennes et qui vise en fait à
réformer l'union européenne et à
demander l'avis des citoyens pour savoir
vers quelle europe
il souhaite aller et pour cela en fait
pardon et pour cela en fait les
institutions européennes ont mis en
place des appels à projets qui
permettent en fait de soutenir des
associations des organismes qui
souhaitent organiser des activités au
niveau local et donc plus concrètement
nous en fait on a rempli on a répondu à
un appel à projet organisée par la
représentation en france de la
commission européenne et donc ils ont
décidé ils ont choisi de nous soutenir
pour le projet europan live mais alors
l'objectif du projet est d'intéresser
les jeunes et les gens éloignés à
l'europe et aux questions de l'europe
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous estimez que
les français ne s'intéressent pas assez
à l'heureux s'est en fait si les
français s'intéressent beaucoup et on se
rend compte que
nous par rapport en fait aux questions
qu'on reçoit nous à la maison de
l'europe des yvelines on se rend compte
qu'il ya un véritable intérêt mais la
grande difficulté c'est que voilà s'il
ya un intérêt
la difficulté en fait que rencontrent
certains de nos certains de nos
concitoyens surtout quand ils sont assez
éloignées c'est qu'en fait l'information
ne vient pas ne vient pas forcément un
peu facilement dans le sens qu'ils ne
vont pas forcément faire ils vont pas
venir ils vont pas avoir la démarche
d'aller chercher par eux-mêmes
l'information par exemple de nous
envoyer un mail de nous contacter ou par
téléphone ou d'aller regarder sur les
réseaux sociaux ainsi de suite et donc
l'objectif de ceux de ce projet c'était
en fait c'était en fait d'inverser le et
ou du moins d'en verser le problème du
moins de résoudre le problème en leur
permettant d'avoir accès beaucoup plus
facilement à ces informations alors
justement l'europe c'est quoi on voit
que certaines personnalités politiques
souhaitent faire sortir la france de
l'europe pendant que d'autres voudraient
renforcer l'importance du pays au sein
de l'union européenne
est ce que l'europe c'est finalement un
fondement politique ou est ce qu'il ya
aussi cette volonté de créer un lien
fort entre tous les pays bas à la base
c'est les 2 c mais concrètement
historiquement qu'on regarde les raisons
pourquoi on a fait l'union européenne
c'est très simple c'est pour éviter la
guerre entre les états alors ça peut
paraître redondant pour beaucoup mais il
faut alors il faut le rappeler on a eu
la seconde guerre mondiale on a eu 60
millions de morts ça a été un carnage
c'est un carnage humain ça a été un
désastre humain et on s'est dit plus
jamais plus jamais ça et donc pour cela
on a mis en place différentes
initiatives on a eu le conseil de
l'europe qui avaient peu qui a pour
vocation de garantir les droits de
l'homme et on s'est dit certain étant
ont décidé d'aller plus loin en se
disant voilà on va essayer d'éviter de
faire on va essayer d'éviter que les
guerres ce que les guerres puis se ré
apparaître sur le territoire européen et
donc on va aller un peu plus loin et
donc on va essayer déjà de créer une
union économique mais en fait qui va
permettre en fait vu qu'on se rend
interdépendants économiquement des
autres pays ça va nous je schématise
voilà mais vu qu'on a ce liens
d'interdépendance ça permet d'éviter de
se
sa peur voilà ça permet d'éviter de se
refaire la guerre merci beaucoup
olivier chanut ex d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensations je rappelle que vous êtes
chargé de mission à la maison de
l'europe des yvelines il y aura aussi
des événements défunt des événements
pardon comme des conférences débats lors
de lors de ce projet comme chaque
semaine nous vous faisons découvrir
celles et ceux qui ont participé à la
construction européenne
aujourd'hui paul henri spaak ce belge né
au 19e siècle
il est l'un des premiers hommes
politiques à avoir une vision de
coopération européenne
son parcours avec europe direct et la
maison de l'europe sous une robe sûr
sensation
paul henri spaak est née le 25 janvier
1899 hr big bruxelles en 1916 paul henri
spaak âgé de 17 ans se porte volontaire
de guerre mais il est arrêté par les
allemands en tentant de passer en
territoire libre et fini la guerre dans
un camp de prisonniers
après des études de droit il se dirige
vers une carrière d'avocat au barreau de
bruxelles
il commence sa carrière politique en
belgique en 1932 où il occupe de
nombreux postes ministériels y compris
la politique étrangère avec la seconde
guerre mondiale il est contraint de
rejoindre l'angleterre et devient membre
du gouvernement belge exilé à londres où
il fait campagne pour une alliance de
l'europe occidentale après la guerre à
partir de 1941 il fut l'un des
promoteurs d'une union douanière entre
la belgique les pays bas et le
luxembourg d'où sont sorties des pays du
benelux en 1944 et dans une moindre
mesure la communauté européenne stack
s'est fait connaître grâce à sa présence
sur la scène internationale il a été le
premier président de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies puis de
nouveau ministre et chef du gouvernement
belge de 1946 à 1949
et secrétaire général de l'organisation
du traité de l'atlantique nord otan
il est à nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères et rejoint le mouvement
européen fondé en 1948 par des pionniers
européens tels que winston churchill
conrad adenauer et alcide de gasperi le
mouvement rassemble des personnalités
politiques et penseurs qui veulent
construire et préserver l'europe ancrer
la belgique dans le camp des grandes
puissances occidentales en formant une
alliance entre la france et la
grande-bretagne et en l'intégrant à
l'otan il préside l'assemblée
consultative du conseil de l'europe de
1949 à 1951 où il défend le plan schuman
il démissionne après que la grande
bretagne refuse il continuera de
défendre l'approbation de la communauté
européenne de défense c'est od à la
chambre des représentants belges sa
vision de l'europe et concret ont des
liens contractuels entre les pays
la paix serait maintenu ils luttent
activement pour la création de la ceca
et d'un marché commun il est cependant
contre une union politique confédérale à
laquelle il préfère une supra
nationalité des institutions paul henri
spaak a joué un rôle essentiel dans la
négociation du traité de rome et la
fondation de la communauté économique
européenne cee
en 1965 il s'attache à résoudre la crise
ouverte par la décision française de ne
plus être membre du conseil crise de la
chaise vide provoqué par charles de
gaulle
il se retire de la vie politique en 1966
est mort le 31 juillet 1972 à bruxelles
son engagement pour la construction
européenne lui vaut le surnom de
monsieur roch
il est considéré comme l'un des pères de
l'europe une aile du parlement européen
de bruxelles portent son nom
zone europe l'invité politique je reçois
aujourd'hui nicolas bay vous êtes député
européen vice-président du groupe
identité et démocratie bonjour bonjour
alors je voudrais d'abord qu'on parle de
la turquie et du bras de fer qui
l'oppose à l'union européenne la turquie
est candidate pour ed adhérer à l'union
européenne un processus qui est dans
l'impasse
mais la turquie menace régulièrement
l'union européenne de laisser passer des
millions de réfugiés bloqués à sa
frontière récemment l'union européenne
s'est accordée sur un budget de près de
14 milliards d'euros pour aider les
candidats à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne dont la turquie
quel est votre sentiment justement à ce
sujet à mon sentiment c'est que ça fait
des années et des années que les
citoyens européens au travers des
institutions européennes payent des
sommes considérables turquie dans
l'espoir des airs de la sphère ads qui
est totalement farfelu comme idée la
turquie n'est européenne ni par son
histoire ni par sa culture ni par sa
géographie et par conséquent bien sûr
nous devons avoir des relations
privilégiées avec les pays qui sont
immédiatement limitrophes de l'europe et
la turquie en fait partie mais
évidemment elle n'a pas vocation à
intégrer l'union européenne ou alors
cela dénaturerait totalement une union
européenne notre monde voit bien déjà
qu'à la fois dans son fonctionnement
comme de ses orientations politiques
elle est totalement en panne et
totalement comment dire inadaptée aux
enjeux et aux attentes des citoyens
la turquie a multiplié ces dernières
années sous l'impulsion d'erdogan les
provocations à l'égard des pays
européens
les forages illégaux dans les eaux
chypriotes les attaques contre la france
directement sur une de nos frégate en
méditerranée orientale
le soutien aux factions islamistes en
syrie le faction le soutien aux
islamistes en libye
le
comme on dit à la déstabilisation de
l'arménie et l'hostilité à l'arménie
bref la turquie se comporte comme un
adversaire
donc il faut arrêter de traiter la
turquie comme un partenaire carré
vocation à intégrer l'union européenne
on a déjà versé en vain en 50 milliards
d'euros à la turquie au travers des
fonds de préadhésion au travers des
fonds de contrôle de l'immigration et au
travers des investissements de la banque
européenne d'investissement donc il faut
sortir de ce schéma là il faut sortir de
là de l'impasse puisque on voit bien que
ado gagnent c'est le chantage car c'est
bien là faut mettre en oeuvre des
sanctions il faut mettre en oeuvre des
mesures de rétorsion par exemple la
turquie est en union douanière avec
l'union européenne depuis 1995 ça lui
permet de faire un gros volume de son
commerce extérieur vers le marché
européen est bien supprimons omettons en
cause cette union douanière je pense que
ça calmera les ardeurs d'erdogan voilà
on a des moyens de rétorsion
simplement quand gâcher la van der leyen
et charles michel viennent au nom des
institutions européennes à ankara ils
sont humiliés par erdogan
ils sont incapables de tenir un discours
de fermeté
voilà c'est que la faut réagir tout de
suite bien sûr il faut avec beaucoup de
fermeté et dire clairement que non
seulement on n'accepte pas le chantage
migratoire qu'on va renforcer nos
frontières extérieures mais que de
surcroît on va traiter la turquie comme
une comme un adversaire si elle se
comporte comme un adversaire et qu'on
pourra être d'ailleurs remettre
commencer par remettre en cause la
présence dans l'otan de la turquie qui
pose évidemment un vrai problème parce
que la menace aujourd'hui pour les pays
qui composent l'otan c'est évidemment
plus le bloc soviétique qui n'est qu'à
disparus ou la russie qui ne constitue
pas une menace
la menace c'est l'islamisme et ados
gagnent aujourd'hui se comporte souvent
comme un allié des islamistes et les
soutient directement ou indirectement
donc sa présence dans l'otan posent une
véritable question un véritable problème
et puis il faut il faut évidemment
multiplier les échos mondiale et se mons
à l'égard des ados gagnent et brandi à
les sanctions de manière très claire ce
qu'aujourd'hui les institutions
européennes ne font pas ils se
contentent de larmoyer un peu sur les
considérations de politique intérieure
turque sur la manière dont les partis
d'opposition sont traités en turquie
tout ça n'est sans doute pas faux mais
c'est pas notre sujet votre sujet c'est
l'intérêt des nations européennes face à
la turquie la turquie se comporte comme
un adversaire il n'est pas question de
quand
et à traiter la turquie comme un
partenaire ou un partenaire potentiel
vous parlez de crise migratoire
justement il ya quelques instants il ya
quelques semaines
huit mille migrants sont arrivés à ceuta
une enclave espagnole au nord du maroc
une majorité de ces migrants ont été a
été expulsée au maroc
vous avez déclaré que l'union européenne
et le gouvernement socialiste espagnol
sont incapables de protéger les
frontières extérieures
mais si vous y voyez aussi un chantage
du migratoire de la part du maroc
comment est ce que vous expliquez que le
maroc rentre aussi dans ce bras de fer
oui c'est assez dommage mais c'est pas
étonnant parce qu'en été le maroc n'a
pas accepté et ça on peut le comprendre
que le gouvernement socialiste espagnol
accueille l'une des figures du front
polisario qui est une organisation
terroriste soutenu par l'algérie qui a
eu mais en cause l'intégrité
territoriale marocaine sur le sahara
occidental est donc évidemment le fait
que l'espagne accueille une personnalité
du front polisario a énervé les
marocains et comme il voit l'exemple
d'erdogan qui fait du chantage
migratoires et ça marche
eh bien il faut essayer d'en faire
autant sur cette enclaves de ceuta qu'il
faut bien l'expliquer est en réalité une
enclave espagnole sur le continent
africain ca sur le territoire marocain
en quelque sorte de l'autre côté du
détroit de gibraltar donc c'était assez
aisé de faire du du chantage migratoires
et d'envoyer des migrants sur ceuta
mais là encore l'union européenne se
révèle totalement défaillante parce que
y'a aucune réaction de fermeté il faut
être capable de protéger les frontières
extérieures et il faut sortir de la
logique de la libre circulation totale
qui aboutit non seulement avoir nos
frontières extérieures insuffisamment
protégé le magasin s'est dit seulement
que vous proposez voilà mes avoirs de
surcroît aujourd'hui il n'y voit
circuler son total à l'intérieur du
continent européen
à cause de schengen qui fait que celui
qui entre qui parvient à entrer
n'importe où sur le sol européen que ce
soit par l'espagne que ce soit par
l'italie que ce soit par la grèce ou par
la route des balkans et bien ensuite il
peut s'égayer d'un tueur circuler
librement avec souvent la certitude de
total régularisé de ne jamais être
inquiété d'un diadème et expulsé vous
pensez que le salon est un single
devrait être remodelé ou en tout cas à
rediscuter oui bien sûr les accords de
schengen ils ont été bien mis en oeuvre
en 1996
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette libre
circulation des hommes qui est une des
séduisantes bien ça aboutit à la libre
circulation des clandestins les
associations parfois des terroristes à
la libre circulation aussi des armes et
des trafics divers et donc il faut
établir des contrôles aux frontières
ça veut pas dire que l'on elles sont
systématiquement fermées bien sûr il
faut permettre le déplacement des gens
pour les considérations familiales
professionnelles touristique mais il
faut être capable d'établir des
contrôles aux frontières et surtout par
dessus tout protéger les frontières
extérieures alors un mot justement sur
les frontières extérieures on va parler
de l'agencé européenne frontex agents se
gardent de frontières les garde-côtes
qui a été créée en 2004 ses moyens et
ses missions été renforcée récemment
justement face à la crise migratoire
dont on parle lors d'une réunion du
groupe de travail feront texte vous
évoquez le fait que des migrants adultes
se font passer régulièrement pour des
migrants mineurs
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour
lutter contre ça est ce qu'on peut
vraiment lutter contre ça mais plusieurs
choses d'abord frontex a une mission
c'est protéger les frontières
extérieures en soutien aux états membres
c'est à dire en soutien aux gardes côtes
et aux gardes frontières des états
membres aujourd'hui il ya une petite
offensive une petite cabale contre
frontex parce que frontex va être doté
de plus d'agents pour être plus efficace
dans sa mission il faut bien dire
qu'aujourd'hui bien souvent
malheureusement frontex ne fait
qu'accompagner des flux migratoires vers
le continent européen et sécurisé en
quelque sorte la traversée de ce qui
pourtant à y vit légalement sur le sur
le sol européen
donc il faut évidemment sortir de ce
modèle le directeur actuel de frontex
qui est un français qui se veulent
fabrice et l'algérie a l'ambition de
faire de frontex un vrai corps de garde
côtes et gardes frontières européens
pour protéger les frontières extérieures
et là il fait l'objet d'une offensive de
la part des ong pro migrants de la part
de la gauche européenne qu'il accuse de
tous les maux simplement parce qu'il
veut exercer la mission qui lui a été
d'ailleurs d'évoluer de manière très
officielle par le parlement par le
conseil même par la commission donc
évidemment il faut renforcer frontex
il faut renforcer de manière générale
les cons le contrôle de nos frontières
extérieures s'agissant des migrants
mineurs
on nous parle toujours de mineurs isolés
on sait que beaucoup de ces de ceux qui
se prétendent mineurs ne le sont pas ils
sont souvent majeur parfois depuis
plusieurs années et comment est-ce qu'on
peut le savoir eh bien il faut pratiquer
des tests osseux ou détestent dentaire
c'est assez aisé semaines imposé sa pose
pas de difficulté bien sûr il faut le
prévoir dans la législation ça pose
aucune difficulté
ça n'est pas attentatoire à la dignité
de qui que ce soit et ça permettrait
justement aussi de protéger ceux qui
sont réellement des mineurs parce qu'il
est évident que quand on a des beaucoup
de ces mineurs qui aurait été son image
assez aboutie en pratique à ce que des
vrais mineurs se retrouve au milieu
comme mondiale dans des centres de
rétention notamment au milieu d'adultes
donc c'est pas vrai c'est évidemment
aussi dans un but de protection des
mineurs et puis disons les choses
clairement
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un était
mineure et qu'il entre sur le sol
européen qu'il a vocation à y rester
la vocation à ce qu'on a plus que le
regroupement familial
il avait donc il a vocation à retrouver
ses parents pour ne passait pas une
famille est passé par les enfants des
parents et être renvoyés dans leur pays
d'origine ou vers le pays duquel ils y
arrivent très bien merci beaucoup
nicolas bay d'avoir été mon invité
aujourd'hui je rappelle que vous êtes
député européen et vice-président du
groupe identité et démocratie saône robe
sûr sensation
une invitation au voyage à présent un
voyage dans l'assiette cette semaine
nous vous faisons découvrir le fish and
chips un plat typiquement britannique la
recette avec quentin du restaurant
poppys à rouen en seine-maritime zone
europe voyage alors bonjour je m'appelle
quentin avec mon associé léonie on a
fondé pop il ya quatre ans donc on
propose la recette traditionnelle de
fish and chips qui vient tout simplement
des des migrants portugais et espagnols
qui lorsqu'il se fait chasser la
péninsule en partie migrer en angleterre
et ont apporté beaucoup de recettes à
base de friture dont le fish and chips
donc nous pour cela on s'est formé en
aller en angleterre pour se former pour
vraiment à prendre la recette
traditionnelle
alors bien sûr pour cuisiner un fish and
chips
il faut une bonne pâte en angleterre on
dîne batteur et l'abatteur s compose
essentiellement soit de bière soit d'eau
gazeuse et la farine qu'on mélange
jusqu'à avoir une texture onctueuse
alors ensuite il faut du poisson frais
bien évidemment du citron des pommes de
terre au fait des frites et une pincée
de sel au dessus du au dessus du fish
and chips et après les puristes diront
qu'il faut prendre du viagra de malte
qui est le vinaigre qui est un vinaigre
particulier qui rajoute une une saveur
vraiment l'amour est cerise au poisson
et ensuite un fish and chips
s'accompagne d'une sauce tartare une
sauce tartare maison bien sûr pour cela
il faut faire une mayonnaise maison
les éléments ensuite pour composer la
tartare il faut des échalotes
il faut des quatre camps nichons persil
ciboulette et et sera vous et là vous
aurez une sauce tartare excellente alors
bienvenue en cuisine il fait un peu
chaud avec les friteuses alors l'élément
de base
bien sûr c'est de la farine et ensuite
de l'eau hop
hop
alors je verse l'eau doucement dans le
bbl alors nous on le fait avec le avec
le batteur finalement on peut aussi
faire à la main alors je verse tout
doucement de la farine
harper
et vraiment à la pâte est vraiment très
simple à faire c'est vraiment deux
éléments soient de la ville soit de la
bière et de l'eau soit la bière et de la
farine par dont le souhait de l'eau
pétillante et de la farine une fois que
là la patte ou l'abatteur comme une
commune comme ils disent en beauté est
finalement et épaisse mais pas trop quoi
ça veut dire que la pâte est prêt à être
free finalement attendre encore hop on
va accélérer davantage
hélas
on est tout bon est la bonne la bonne
texture pas trop épaisses mais
suffisamment pour que la batteur colle
au col adhère aux poissons donc là tout
simplement
je dispose la pâte ici je vérifie que la
friteuse et et bien à température up à
180° de préférence hélas le poisson il
est ici donc c'est de l'arrivage de ce
matin aujourd'hui ça va du filet de
merlu on peut aussi très bien utiliser
du filet de cabillaud ou ou un autre
fils et sa peluche jaune ou encore
maître du dos si on veut
donc l'objectif c'est de talent est
taillé une belle pièce nous on va à peu
près des filets 240 g
hop hop voici on va disposer un tout
petit peu de sel dessus
et c'est tout
l'idée c'est le badigeonner de farine
pour que la pâte adhère aux poissons
donc voilà on retombe d'un poisson aucun
départ tôt on tape atteint un peu opaque
un excès de farine est tout simplement
on va attraper le poisson dans la pâte à
pain dur voici ont laissé couler
légèrement et hop on peut verser
tranquillement dans la friteuse et voilà
la magie opère
donc voilà l'idée c'est d'attendre six
minutes un pouvoir faire cuire des
frites en même temps avoir une feuille
la panure commence à être adoré les
frites également on va pouvoir revoir
sortir et dresser l'assiette
je dispose le jus de citron
tac
et la voici un cliché hot chips à
l'anglais et voilà
après déguster alors voilà le fish and
chips et en assiette et maintenant vous
allez ma compagne il faut faire la
terreur alors pour faire la tartare on a
besoin d eux premièrement hop on va les
blanchir dans le robot
une fois que les autres ont blanchi on
va pouvoir ajouter le jus de citron
ap
ainsi trois pouvoir ajouter la moutarde
alors ensuite ouvert celle de lille
vous continuez vers les juges du ta mére
des trois ferme
et voilà c'est parfait alors du coup je
vais couper un peu de persil on peut le
hacher grossièrement on le met
directement sur la mayonnaise la
ciboulette pareil ensuite on met les
échalotes
hop on va rajouter les clans nichons
donc je couds grossièrement ce que c'est
la machine qui va qui va mixer et faire
des morceaux un peu plus fin les quatre
jeux les verse directement dedans
ensuite je mets l'estragon le sel et
poivre
hop on va finir par mélanger le tout à
quoi
et pas qu mélange est homogène on va
pouvoir arrêter la machine on va prendre
la sauce tartare qui est la sauce
indispensable pour accompagner le
fichier le fish comme les prêteurs voici
et c'est prêt à être servi
malabo si les expressions populaires
pleuvoir en abondance les français
disent pleuvoir comme vache qui pisse
pour les grecs
il pleut des pieds de chaise que dit-on
ailleurs regardez zone europe
expression d'ici et d'ailleurs en
allemagne on dit eric note 4 secondes ce
qui signifie il pleut des chats et des
chiens
en italie on dit puis reverrai à katyn
elle cela signifie pleuvoir à cuvette
aurait mené on dit ce qui veut dire il
pleut des chiens et des chats zone
europe s'est terminée merci aux équipes
techniques du parlement européen de
strasbourg
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78
rendez vous la semaine prochaine très
bonne soirée sonne europe / sensations